Howdy's since fans today is a happy day
we finally after much too long a wait
have a new website and it's sexy as hell
meet the new cinema since calm thanks to
the folks over at Squarespace we now
have a place that if I were a fan I
would want to hang out all our content
is consumable there and is easily found
through a variety of playlists and
filters wanted to swatch our sins videos
on Marvel movies you can how about by
genre like sci-fi or Western ukm how
about filtering my shows like how to
make or conversations with myself you
can can one switch over to music video
sins without leaving the page you can
want to order a shirt you can there's
even a page just for my book the Able's
which you can pre-order now and we've
even started an email list so you can
add your email to receive news and
updates on all things cinemasins and
this is the best website ever but wait
there's more there are some really great
features coming very soon that i think
you're gonna like we're going through
the hotline right now looking for the
best fan narrated movie sins to put
under each video so if you think we
missed one on a video or if you think we
could have worded this in better or
something
call the hotline state the movie's name
then narrate your scent and you could
see your audio directly under the video
someday soon hopefully this will clear
up how we hope to use the hotline moving
forward and maybe get some more of you
leaving actual sins as opposed to
rambling voice mass not that we don't
freaking love rambling voicemails
because we do the other new feature
coming soon that I think many of you
will enjoy is script notes we're going
to be adding the script of sins from
each movie underneath that video along
our website and then you'll have the
ability to leave comments on it sort of
like a SoundCloud function for words so
again more chances to point out your
favorite moments or where we screwed up
and stuff like that we will be adding
written content to the blog we've got
our social media stuff up here at the
top and have given you easy quick links
for sharing content if you're into that
I just am really freaking love this
website Thank You Squarespace you
knocked it out of the park now stop
watching this video and go check out the
new cinemas INSCOM we think you're gonna
love it
[Music]